COLUMBUS.
THE PUCK IS  FROM STEVEN
STAMKOS!
THOSE TWO GUYS REMAINED LOOKS O
SIDE, THAT WAS FOOLED.
I THINK THEY WERE READY  KUCHER
BOGOSIAN, PICKED UP  BY OUT IN
THE BLUE JACKETS T THE
OTHER SIDE.LIKE THAT, HE MIGHT
POWER-PLAY TIME.
REALLY GOOD STUFF, FROM NICK
PAUL.
>> Dave: READ THE RUSH
AS WELL AS ANY GOALIE IN THE
LEAGUE.
THERE WAS NOTHING TO LOOK AT, S
>> SHOT.OF GAMES.
SQUEEZETAKING THE PASS AWAY.
VASILEVSKIY HAS TO TRUST.
NO PAST, NO PASS.
LOOK W W
BLANKENBURG, PRESSURE, BY
CIRELLI.
POPPED UP.IN ONE-ON-ONE, WITH K
HERE IS KUCHEROVOV
1-1. WHAT A CHANCE THE
LIGHTNINAT CENTER. ANOTHER FRIE
STEVEN STAMKOS, WITH POINT 99!
HE JUST FULL THE DEFENDERS ALL
CENTER ICE.E.
DO NOT SEE ERIK CERNAK.
FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN HIS SPECAT PUCK,
EVERYWHERE. HIGH STICK.
HERE IS BJORKSTRAND.STAMKOS, AG
SAVED, BY MERZRZTHE
DEFENSEMAN.
BIG STOP, BY MERZLIKINS!
ON THE REBOUND,
I THINK THEY WILL HAVE SOME
OFF A BAD ANGLE.
JACKETS.
KUKAN, PASS ATTEMPTS. OF THE NE
SCORES!
KUCHEROV WAITED AND WAITED AND
HAS ON DRIP A LOT ONDREJ WITH S
TURNS BACK, TOWARDS